mario plus rabbids combines two
franchises into something totally
different
a turn-based strategy game but don't let
the mario style graphics and goofy
screaming rabbits fool you
mario plus rabbids is a deep strategy
game in the style of xcom
enemy unknown and it'll test your
strategy skills
to help you transition from
mild-mannered plumber to mushroom
kingdom defender we've compiled these 9
tips to get you into the right mindset
we have more reviews guides and hot
gameplay coming your way so make sure to
subscribe
so you don't miss a thing alright let's
get to it
[Music]
mario plus rabbids has a straightforward
cover system in which hiding behind
smaller walls makes characters half as
likely to get hit
by incoming shots and hiding behind
taller walls makes shots impossible to
land
flanking enemies is key but one of the
unique things about mario plus rabbits
is that you can deal damage to enemies
when your characters move
and vice versa don't forget every time
you take a turn in battle that if an
enemy is in range you can stop
by and slide tackle them without
compromising your character's ability to
reach their destination
or to perform other actions try to do
movement damage every turn
it's easy to forget
at the beginning of every battle you can
use the tacticam by hitting x to survey
the battlefield and see what you're up
against
you should always check things out
before you start after the first few
battles you're able to switch characters
at the start of every new fight to
better adjust your team for what you're
facing
take note of the terrain your objectives
and what kind of enemies are on the
field
then assemble the team that's best
equipped to handle the fight
[Music]
between battles you're able to wander
around the mushroom kingdom and like
most mario games there are tons of
secrets
always check for side paths or alternate
ways to get to places because they
usually hold
extra coins you can use to buy upgraded
guns lots of the secrets you find in
treasure chests are unlockables like 3d
models and soundtrack songs you can view
at the museum near peach's castle
but many also contain weapons that you
can then purchase
getting new guns is essential in mario
plus rabbids so always take the time to
look around for hidden stuff
and try returning to old areas when you
have new abilities
[Music]
though there are a lot of coins
scattered throughout mario plus rabbits
guns are expensive and you have limited
funds
it's tempting to try to keep everyone in
your group outfitted with the best gear
but as you unlock more characters and
secondary weapons it'll be tough to keep
up
instead save your money and use your
pre-battle preparation phase to buy new
guns for the characters you plan to use
next
that way you can afford the best stuff
for the characters you need when you
need it
[Music]
some battles in mario plus rabbits have
you taking down all the enemies on the
field
but plenty of others have different
objectives sometimes shooting isn't the
best plan
and since the game ranks your play based
on how fast you clear a battle and how
many of your characters survive you have
an incentive to play efficiently
and boss fights for instance taking out
the boss instead of focusing on smaller
enemies can end the battle quicker
mario plus rabbids throws a lot of stuff
your way as you progress
including new enemies new battlefields
and new allies
you'll spend much of the game learning
new concepts and adapting to different
conditions so don't be afraid to fail
building the right team for any given
fight can be tough and learning how
different characters interact and can
work together
is essential for success mario plus
rabbids also includes a feature that
lets you replay old battles to get a
better rank so don't be afraid to
experiment and learn from your mistakes
[Music]
every time you clear a world in mario
plus rabbits you earn power orbs you can
spend to increase their abilities
ranking up your characters is essential
to success so don't sleep on upgrading
them
you likely won't be able to afford every
upgrade for every character even by the
end of the game but
you can use upgrades to create a
playstyle do you prefer using lots of
character skills or being highly mobile
want some characters to be damaged
sponges you can adjust how your team
works significantly
if you invest in the right areas
essential to being great at mario plus
rabbids and beating some of the tougher
battles and bosses is effectively using
complementary characters
for instance you can use rabin mario's
magnet dance to draw enemies out of
cover
and luigi's steely stare to take
reaction shots triggered by their motion
you can deploy skills mid-turn to use
them to make some pretty powerful
combinations so keep experimenting and
don't ignore any character skills
as you move through mario plus rabbids
you often find areas you can't reach
because you lack abilities you unlock a
new exploration ability at the end of
each chapter so it's worth it to head
back and try to find the things you
missed
these unexplored places often yield
handy weapons
and dropping back through these areas
you've already cleared lets you try
challenge missions for extra coins and
power orbs
if you're struggling try heading back to
places you've already been to upgrade
your characters
you can also use the time machine near
peach's castle to replay old battles and
earn more coins
should you need them mario plus rabbits
can be tough if you haven't played many
turn-based strategy games but hopefully
these tips help you out if you have any
tips drop them in the comments below to
help out your fellow plumbers and if
you're confused as to why there are
rabbids in the mario universe click on
this video right here for the intro
cutscene of mario plus rabbids kingdom
battle
thank you for watching